what were search and rescue boats
returned to port
prepared for a change of mission a day
after indonesia's navy declared a
missing submarine
sunk with 53 souls on board
kri and angala 402 last saw the surface
on wednesday off the coast of bali
debris that's been found indicates its
hull collapsed under pressure
the indonesian navy has changed the
status of krai nangala
from missing to drowned or sunk
submarine
all of us indonesians express our deep
sorrow over this tragedy
especially to the families of the
submarine crew
members of the public hopeful that the
crew would be found alive
now send their condolences
i hope that the family members of the
victims will soon get good news from it
and the submarine will be found soon no
matter how the condition is
and i hope the family is strong enough
to face it
i can imagine it was a difficult moment
for the crew
and it was deep down under the sea but
also even if there is advanced
technology
there must have been human error during
the operation
so this could be a learning opportunity
and advice to the government to improve
the technology
and be careful using it because people's
lives are at stake
others are sharing a video of the men
that's become a viral tribute
of a submarine crew on eternal patrol
[Music]
andrew chappelle al jazeera